we welcome them back Christopher
Hitchins Vanity Fair good morning
mornings for being with us and the
author of this book no one left to lie
to you talk about it inside the book
how'd you come up with this title
there's a guy was God there is a God
good Michael J of shippers David
shippers who was some a Chicago Democrat
rather of the old school prosecutor who
was hired by Henry hard to be chief
counsel for the House Judiciary
Committee and in his summary speech
closing speech to the to the impeachment
debate before the committee he said look
the president's now lied in the civil
deposition he's lied to a grand jury
he's lied to what his cabinet his
notorious colleagues to his family to
the American people though there's no
one left to lie to and I was watching
this I had I had an earlier title in
mind for the book it was even in the
catalog already the publishers were
furious when I haven't seen this I was
watching him at Miami Airport on Airport
TV I thought that's got to be the title
it's perfect what was the original title
was going to be asked not tell not why
did you when your publisher select this
picture for the cover I had no idea till
I sat down with the design people how
many pictures the were Clinton looking
both smug and wicked and mendacious or
at the same time but that is almost the
perfect one and there's also a hint of
triumph here this one is if he really
does feel I think that's everybody I
don't think that can't be anyone left
Elijah and I think my book is addressed
to all the people who wanted to be lied
to
and you still do so in a way he wins
again until I can turn the time when I
say the name Sidney Blumenthal what
comes to mind old friend of mine
unfortunately also an old friend of mr.
Clinton's I'm great admirer of and
worker for and alas as he said to the
Senate went in his testimony one of
those who was lied to I mean he realizes
now that mr. Clinton told him a full
story Monica Lewinsky and other matters
and let him shows what kind of a friend
mr. Clinton is let him go into the grand
jury and retell this false and
defamatory story
the enjoy was me and I was prepared to
say as much
when asked by the House Judiciary
Committee and rather to my surprise
because Sydney had denied telling anyone
else it became a huge story
I mean for her there was a week-long
flap which rather I thought rather
distracted attention from from the main
story which was then the President had
authored a effectively a slander against
a former comfort woman of his for whom
he had no further use that's the kind of
guy here's what quite often does and had
it circulated in such a way I thought is
to constitute an obstruction of justice
because it was a threat to her as well
as her as well as a slander offer I
can't find the quote in here but in the
conversation that you had with any
Blumenthal someone's been reading it
closely I have read it actually but but
and I'm going to paraphrase you you
allude to the fact that Sidney
Blumenthal said we're going to take care
of one ADA Broderick
that's not exactly what you wrote when
it was it was actually Kathleen Willey
Kathleen Willey I'm sorry we wouldn't
well I know it's hard to keep all these
female victims in perspective isn't it I
think I can I can now tell them apart
but it's it's an effort Kathleen Willey
the week before I had my lunch with
Sidney Katherine would have gone on 60
minutes to say that she'd be the
recipient of unwelcome attention to the
president I thought she looked like she
was telling the truth
I have heard sense that she's been
subjected to various kinds of
intimidation from I was sort of rather
mysterious kind about it I brought it up
with said he only came up at the
luncheon I remember him he said that
well her numbers are high now you know
the polls in from people thinking she
was credible but they'll be down by the
end of the week and what had happened
was I didn't like the tone of it you
know so that we will soon fix her kind
of thing but the following day I think
it was the White House found and
released all the private memos between
her and the president some of them quite
affectionate you know and admiring she
as if she is or was a very Clinton Hoyt
Democrat and what angered me about that
they found this and put them out in a
day more
those have been subpoenaed not not long
before by the paula jones alliance the
same memos and they wanted any any and
all paper contact between the president
and ms Willie right Houston sorry we
just can't seem to find that we just
can't find that you can subpoena us all
we want we can't put our hands on the
papers once they needed to apply to
sixty minutes there they filed the
papers in short order and that struck me
as so typical of the mo of this White
House there's a tenth rate and nasty and
under handle me I don't like everything
about about this president and his
tactics midway through the book you
point out first of all that the
President had precisely two cabinet
meetings in 1998 you know count them to
one in January to lie to the cabinet in
one in August to tell him he was going
to have to tell some bit of the truth
after all and sorry about that guys he
didn't really say sorry as a matter of
fact he defended himself you know the
usual bombastic way when Donna
shillelagh said well you know you could
get the impression mr. president that
you kind of put yourself ahead of you
know all other considerations your
friends your policies your or value
really were thinking of yourself he
whirled on her and said well you're the
sort of person who would preferred Nixon
to Kennedy why did he say that
I think he'll say anything that was the
comment that was overheard afterwards
she'll say try and I think he's a
complete saw obsessed he said he has
some and he's completely without scruple
but I think the consequences of the
first meeting of a graver ones because
at the end of that meeting whether he
whether the cabinet were persuaded by
his lying or not I don't know in their
hearts so to speak but they were induced
to go out into the street vice president
did and the secretary state didn't make
complete abject fools of themselves by
saying they were absolutely sure he was
telling the truth now that's what
everyone sees when they see Madeline
Albright coming to a negotiation now
let's see
oh well that great there's the woman who
believed the president about Monica
Lewinsky and we're done stood outside in
the street and said everything's fine
nobody resigned only one person has
resigned from this administration it
wasn't over any of these things and it
wasn't someone who'd been humiliated as
these people were they've lost
they've lost all their pride all their
dignity
in litter in this chapter you say that
I've known a number of people who work
for him or with him and who have worked
with this man they act like cult members
while they are still under the spell and
talk like X cult members as soon as they
have broken away yes that's true George
Stephanopoulos George is the one I know
the best yeah it may be in slightly
unfair to say that he actually
completely like a cult member while he
was working there he was he's a
relatively straight guy and a rather
decent I think but you know he had to
often stand up for defend impossible
positions he talks mushroomy he talks
much like an ex-con member now he's left
they see who talks like someone who will
say this is you know believe it or not
trust me I used to believe this this is
how I used to think and now I can't
imagine her idea but I don't think it
anymore that looks very familiar to me
and let me bring up one another point
then we'll get to calls you guys about
you know you thought well I'm laughing
let me read this and then I'll have you
follow up you talked about David Geffen
Steven Spielberg of DreamWorks who have
contributed close to $400,000 in two
hundred thirty six thousand dollars to
the Clintons of the Democratic Party the
waltons of Walmart two hundred sixteen
thousand dollars in Larry and Sheila
Lawrence of the Hotel del Coronado and
their associated real estates a hundred
thousand dollars of contributions by
their companies or their employees to
the President or the Democratic Party do
you go on to say that mr. Lawrence later
achieved a brief brief celebrity by his
Triple Crown of buying lying and dying
yeah explain well he had his wife gave
all this money and therefore they got
into the Lincoln Bedroom because as you
know this president knows well and this
may be because I'm an immigrant to this
country I am to easily overcome with
reverence but it seems to me one of the
things about clintonism isn't it so it's
profaned is blaspheme by telling the
Oval Office into a so cheap
massage parlor the Lincoln Bedroom into
it so cheap motel for fat cats and
Arlington Cemetery into something that
can be franchised for fundraising mr.
Lawrence
I invented a war record for himself so
that he could so that he could along
with a hefty donation have himself
buried in Arlington Cemetery and his
wife appointed to diplomatic positions
and so on when it was all discovered but
this has been a fraud I mean that the
money shouldn't really been handed over
anyway we had to be dug up out of
Arlington Cemetery and reburied now that
would get me down if if I was some a
patriotic American which I can't claim
to be but I was appalled and rather
astonished that it didn't get people
down that the things that we're supposed
to teach the children about lying the
Lincoln Bedroom mr. Lincoln's bedroom
for heaven's sake uses a motel the Oval
Office used as a massage parlor and
Byington cemetery uses a jump for lying
flat cut fundraiser this is appalling
isn't it and you've everyone said but
these are private matters leave the
garland well my impression is that now
that it's over and he's walked just
literally walk got clean away with
everything and not apologized and said
that he doesn't regard impeachment as a
disgrace they ensure that now people are
turning away from him and for reasons
they can't quite explain I have a lot of
people come up to me now and say you
know I didn't agree with you about this
or I don't agree with you about that but
when he comes on the TV now I can't
watch it anymore I'm really hoping that
that's going to become general and if
you have if you can't be thrown out of
office and these people will turn their
backs on him the book is called no one
left to lie to our guest is Christopher
Hitchens del Mar California on our
conservative line good morning good
morning I continue to be very troubled
by the so called trial that took place
in the Senate I wonder if you can reveal
anything to me why a Republican Senate
would was so accommodating to the other
side I heard mr. shivers who I thought
should have really done the trial say
that Joseph Biden a Democrat who from
Robert Bork saying vetoed him then why
did Trent Lott allow this trial really
not to take place even the Republican
senators from Maine didn't want
witnesses live witnesses I mean it was
what seven hours of video
taped testimony of a president who I
believe they all know is unfit to be
there and we probably wouldn't have this
war if they had convicted him
thanks caller um its I can on the
weekend after there was raw about my
testimony to the House Judiciary
Committee I did get a call at home as
I've been told I might from a from a
senator senior Democrat guy actually
quite admire I can't give his name alas
but who said that he after what I had
said in other things that he'd learned
he was now determined that he would
virtue convict on certainly on the count
of obstruction of justice
I was I was impressed and then he began
to talk about how well maybe the things
been presented into partisan away and I
remember thinking I wonder if he really
is going to vote and of course that day
to the lasting shame of the Democratic
Party he voted not not one single
Democratic senator version two to
convict on the evidence which was quite
clearly preposterous and that was the
most noticeable thing but the lady
questioners quite right to say that
there wasn't a mysterious lack of
enthusiasm on the Republican side I
would it would take a long time to
explain all the reasons I think why
that's true but in effect that we have
been a Clinton Gingrich Co presidency
until quite recently the Republican
probably had no real political quarrel
with the president the president uh
floor was enacting most of their program
and in the middle indeed of the of the
trial itself he in AB steppings
constitutes vote-buying in the potential
jury announces yes after all he is going
to not just test but build the Star Wars
the SDI system the most expensive and
destabilizing and dangerous and wasteful
boondoggle in your tree and politically
in indeed in political and economic
history so they were aware of that they
had the president where they wanted him
is they okay you enact our agenda we
might go easy on you secondly was that
the Republican Party knows how to watch
Wall Street and the opinion polls as
well as anybody else does perhaps a
little better certainly no worse and it
seemed to be the ruling of Wall Street
and the Dow Jones on the opinion polls
that that impeachment was a waste of
time or diversion
the best and at a meeting in Palm Beach
of I think it's called the Golden Eagles
or somesuch
it's the Republican backers of what
sometimes said I called the donor
community which was makes me know the
party had been told pretty much knew who
cares about whether there's a crook as
president there are worse things than a
crooked president if diners you know
what policies to pursue get with the
program disclosure law it was capable of
picking up their signal this quote above
the title of the book well-traveled
hyper educated pissed off always funny
is that how you describe yourself the
quotient we should point out is from
voice literary was some of a kind critic
individuals who said that wouldn't be
for me to say the pissed off that I can
I can say is true if now I know that
which I didn't know so just this member
that you can say pissed off at
breakfast-time
seaspar Boone North Carolina for
Christopher Hitchens good morning
I have a question several questions and
points I'd like to bring up one of the
questions kind of rhetorical would be
why is the they're wasting always
telling on fashion Mother Teresa and
Bill Clinton it's pretty much for going
conclusion and I saw what wasn't work on
conclusion well good well it it's pretty
obvious but with what we've got we just
got to do the best with what we've
gotten as far as Mother Teresa you know
who cares she did a job but I saw you on
Fox and looks like Fox on the mother
lode of all Clinton bashes and injures
oh if Fox is going to use you give give
five one hundred percent Christopher
Hitchens okay and one other point is the
real reason why we're in Kosovo is
probably because the CIA didn't support
an H in the State Department didn't
support NFC American millionaire
was a true Democrat that's all be okay
thanks caller that reminds me that I
didn't answer the other lady's question
about how how peach work might have from
averted this war could I just I mean I
think like to try and comprehend both
questions in the same answer I don't
believe no start again in my book I say
that I do believe that the president
used military force in a capricious and
promiscuous way to save his own skin in
Sudan last August the bombings of
Khartoum and of Kabul and also later the
Christmas time or impeachment time
bombings of Baghdad I think I've made
that case if you don't find it
convincing I can say that so far no one
has no one has rebutted or tempted to
about this hypothesis has great deal of
evidence to show the president on his
own initiative used what should have
been American military force for
entirely private and corrupt purposes
relation to his own court calendar it's
emotional he allegation to be made I
think against the president and the
polling fact that it's true hasn't sunk
into people here because I don't think
they can quite take it but they'll have
to face it and of course it's
conditioned the responses of other
nations to any threat or promise made by
the president because they know that at
least they can suspect him of this which
not healthy state of affairs however I
think there was going to be a
confrontation in Kosovo anyway I don't
believe for a moment the president
engineered such things in this man he no
doubt suits him that he can pose as
commander-in-chief while the tox report
on China is coming out and while two
other things such as very believable
rape allegations are circulating but I
don't blame him for taking advantage of
that I mean worse a politician wouldn't
it taste since introducer he's a lousy
commander-in-chief as you can see from
the progress and the war not one of the
things said by him about why it was
being fought or half turned out to be
true but I don't think it's a wag the
dog state of affairs mr. panitch I've
met he was the Californian he's a
Californian sir successful businessman
and friendly enough old political friend
and colleague of Jerry Brown's
and there was a time it looked as if he
might if there was a fair election in
Formula slava he might win
and he was opposed to the atrocities in
Bosnia and the totalitarian coach of the
Velocity's regime and yes it is a shame
in a way he didn't get more support
while he was a life candidate we don't
do anything to help a Serbian opposition
Christopher Hitchens grew up in South
England a graduate of Oxford Oxford
University our next call is from Wichita
Falls Texas good morning I was there
with the president were you know those
talks at the same time did you remember
him no I remember the house where he
lived because it was the number of draft
resisters were there and I was a
supporter of the anti-war movement
I said bottle incog baby was of course a
Belial was my college a Leo he mr.
Clinton's University College 46 leg foot
Rovers where they they used to hang out
and ice to go round help dish our
leaflets and that kind of thing the
president unfortunately turned out to be
not a draft resistible a draft dodger
which is a quite different thing I think
never to be confused those who were
there were very brave young Americans in
that stage who were perhaps to take the
consequences of opposing the war one of
the early signs of mr. Clinton's lousy
character was that he wasn't prepared to
take those consequences he just wanted
to squeeze through and not and avoid the
draft which is not a credible position
to take his roommate strobe Talbot I
remember Talbert I remember I a magazine
and I remember quite well I knew him
Just My Luck Robert rice strobe Talbot
oh so why don't you others know I think
about it your name will come back to me
let's get this call from Texas if you
think of it go ahead caller thanks for
waiting
good morning mr. Hitchens up I think
you're about the lowest life you have
never liked this president you never
liked him I want I want to make a
comment and then I don't have a question
you have been from the very beginning on
to this you're a jury Brown Band and
that kind of people it doesn't matter
who it is that you don't like to run
around the park you do all these things
and you lie yo you people like you have
made a mint off of this president you
write books you have no sources for it
you said they're talking about you knew
greedly oh well I'd like to see the
picture I'd like to see somebody tell me
besides people like you I've been
watching this and I grew
used to live in West menses Arkansas by
the way so I know a little bit about
Arkansas I know a little bit about Paula
Jones and I know her relatives and I
know someone that works for the stage is
named Paula so I mean this is crap it's
a little tiring but now and your books
are running out and I hope you don't
sell one now about Sidney Blumenthal
yeah why do you want to go and get onto
your friends and go on about all this
crap you people are just absolutely
sickening you can't do anything on your
own
you don't write real story you put out
gossip and rumors about other people you
are there okay we'll get a response
thanks caller I quite often get asked if
I've still got Clinton on the bread you
know and in a way I suppose I have I
mean that is partly because as the lady
says I did from the very first time I
saw him in New Hampshire I did think
there was something revolting about him
not something more than a political
disagreement there was a hey Judas
products and his dishonesty but I
thought there was something potentially
monstrous about the guy this was because
I did if you remember the case but he
when he was in trouble in the polls over
Jennifer flowers and he's lying about
her he went back to Arkansas of which
she was still governor and supervised
the execution of a mentally disabled in
fact lobotomized a black defendant call
Ricky rector a very cruel and cold and
nasty attempt to show that he could be a
tough guy and I was appalled by that and
also by the Silence of the Liberals
about it and I have fear it's true I
have to tested him ever since what do
you think if he may have upset it may
have it may have made me sick I don't
know the book is certainly in my mind an
attempt to get him out of my system but
I think now I'll have to stick with it
until the guy's gone one way or another
which isn't thank heaven that long now
as for the mint in case anyone wonders I
mean you try it I hope my publishers are
listening this is published by verso to
small house it's the publishing arm of
the new after review haven't think I've
had an advance yet and if I tell you how
much it was you wouldn't believe
anyway because you'd think I was
low-balling it mrs. Clinton I've met
won't do us any a man I think was five
grand which it has to be like it has to
make that back so this is why I hope
people go to Russia and get it five
thousand dollars to write this year this
is a lot mrs. Clinton well I can't
understand why people think she's owed a
Senate seat somehow it seems that after
all she's done for us we ought to find
her a place in the set I don't get this
at all what has she done for us except
be the self-pitying a robotic defendant
of someone who is a pathological liar
almost certainly a rapist and as I share
in the Brooklyn minor war criminal all
she's done is say that it's always
someone else's fraud that plus I suppose
single very nearly single-handedly took
the work of many people over many years
to build up a consensus on our national
health coverage in universal health care
and just piss it away in a couple of
months so that now there's no question
in anybody's mind health care situation
United States is much worse than when
the Clintons were elected very much was
steeply worse for the just with the
profession and for the patient's because
of the takeover of the whole health care
business by the HMO racket probably one
of the greatest evil social disasters of
the century I don't see that she gets a
Senate seat for that dear Fort Walton
Beach Florida on our conservative line
good morning hello mr. Hitchens I'm a
conservative and I hope I'll be a
contrast to your previous caller she
sounded pretty conservative musician on
mr. Clinton even though we're have
different ideological views my comment
is I would like to ask your opinion or
get your comments on the comparisons
have been made to what's going on in
Kosovo a lot of people have compared the
situation in Kosovo to what's happened
in
in World War two and Hitler and also to
the beginnings of World War one I think
a more appropriate comparison would be
to what happened in Waco under Janet
Reno and the the massacre of innocent
people in in that situation he had a
despotic individual that was supposedly
it was rumoured was conducting
atrocities on the people that were under
his control and then you had the
government step in and with their
jackbooted thugs came in and actually
massacred innocent people and an attempt
to right the wrong that they were they
were attempting to do and my other
concern is the lack of response in the
country for such a thing in other words
there was no there appeared to be no
outrage and I'd like you to get your
comment on that place well I think
there's any comparison at all between
mr. mr. Koresh and mr. Milosevic and
presumably neither do you I don't know
if I don't know whether you intend the
analogy to go that far since you appear
to think that mr. mr. Koresh was was
innocent I mean I don't know that that's
absolutely true I think the science that
it wasn't a very nice organization to
belong to especially if you were a kid
who hadn't had the option of joining
that's usually true of these cult groups
anyway doesn't excuse what the Bureau of
Alcohol firearms and tobacco did which
and as you say it was what a means by
which we discovered that there was yet
another armed and dangerous
para state force in the country this
entailed to come and kick down your door
as if there weren't enough of those
already so I'm with you so far but mr.
Milosevic is is everything that is said
of him I mean you don't have to go and
hit on all that kind of thing but I was
in sorry ever for a while and I've been
in the region of fair bit and I'm
convinced myself that the the charge
that he's an aggressor and a racist and
and a dictator and war criminal are all
absolutely solidly true I the tragedy
for me of the present war is that it's
not being fought for the advertiser
purpose and if the war aims were what we
said they well they're believed to be
namely to get the Kosovo refugees back
home and mr. Milosevic shadow power I
would be impressed but it seems to me
that can't really be the objective the
objective seems more to boot to boost
the credibility another overused word of
a cumbersome and discredited NATO
alliance Westminster Maryland good
morning our moderate line moderate life
good morning never all moderate and
conservative had no idea ahead please
what about extremists where my friends
I'm an extremist from a lot but I
consider myself a moderate now compared
to this speaking I take mr. Hitchens as
being a part of a great tradition on
American television that began I think
probably will go of it all that's too
kind but I'll I'll do my best to accept
it with grace I have a great deal of
trouble with the ability of the American
people to actually uh sum up and get
angry about Kosovo its policy and its
effect if you looked at the condition of
the average Albanian Kosovars they call
them prior to the bombing and now what
have they want I mean their world has
been lost and I'm afraid that American
policy is without you know without an
exit strategy has no way of getting them
back mr. bellos which has an exit
strategy that doesn't hear me or rather
an exodus strategy and he's had one for
a long time and of course everybody knew
that he was planning to do this and
that's what makes it so disgraceful Mike
Kelley did a very good column about this
in the Washington Post and the while ago
he noticed the he noticed the press
briefing given by prime minister Massimo
D'Alema virtually the new the new
Italian leader who'd been in Washington
a couple of weeks before the bombing
wanted me to see the president because
Italy is the frontline country it's the
nearest to Albania that's where the
bases are and that's where the refugees
are going to try and head if they can
splash their way across from Bari that's
where Albanians always try and go
so in all those three where mr. diamond
was entitled to ask you know what the
real plan was that he said in his
briefing so I asked the president what
will you do if we bomb and it doesn't
change when auspicious policy but he
does turn on the Albanian Kosovo
population civilian population perfectly
good question I mean anyone he would be
the fool not to ask it and he told the
press that the president looked at him
as if he was hearing the question for
the first time as if that thought had
not occurred and that he then turned to
sandy Berger I'd hate to be in a
position where I can anywhere allow mr.
Berger for advice I must say and said
well what would we do sandy in that
situation Berger said well I guess we
just keep on bombing well this is
outrageous so let's think Maryland they
then compounded this by saying when the
refugees were immediately kicked out in
their hundreds of thousands and found on
the hillsides of Macedonia and Albania
from the President and from the Joint
Chiefs and from mrs. Albright and mr.
Cohen we were told oh don't reproach us
with that we knew that was going to
happen we're not surprised by this well
we were expecting it they were expecting
it what kind of an admission is that
that makes them accomplices in point of
fact we have to hope for their segments
they're lying because if they're telling
the truth then they would have to go to
the hey that's well as Milosevic and and
be charged with complicity and crimes
against humanity
the reason it's possible they are lying
is that if they knew it was coming then
why were there near blankets and pampers
and food parcels and bottled water the
frontier I mean if they were expecting
this flood of immiseration homeless
terrified people they certainly didn't
look as if they've made any provision
for it and then they said well I tell
you what since you have been kicked out
had it had your lives wrecked and all
that maybe we can have you live on a
barbed wire encampment we've got a Cuba
I mean as the caller just sent you know
you if you didn't laugh you'd have to
cry or you'd have to pretend that you
hadn't noticed and just get on with your
life but the shame of this is
unbelievable it seems to be unbelievable
shame go ahead Silver Spring good
morning good morning I'm a longtime
viewer and 67 year old Africa
American and retired Navy veteran the 25
years of Korean and Vietnam War and mr.
Hitchens
fascinates me and he really gets to the
core of a lot of things I voted for
Clinton twice and I can't stand to watch
him on TV and I hate to say this but as
a mature student of American history I
find him very much American very much
represents what this country is to a
large degree and I have no doubt in my
mind that if he was in Milo services
place he would be just as ruthless in
bloody and if he had it in his power to
really direct the Armed Forces during
his impeachment I think he would have
surrounded the capitol buildings and
probably rounded up all the Republicans
and parade them off somewhere
why did you vote for the President and
neither the two elected twice twice I'm
sorry mr. Joyce trust too many what
would turn the tide for you uh just
watching them on TV is facial
expressions is wiggle worming when you
think of this picture on the cover of
Christopher Hitchens new boy bad bad
yeah it almost nauseates me and a lot of
these facial expressions with no doubt
that he's a smart man
but I don't know I'm looking look at a
response Thanks I guess believe that Oh
Jay was guilty too so my wife's go round
and round all these various subjects but
since I'm fully retired I'm a c-span
attic and I watch it constantly you know
and I appreciate getting through to
express my humble opinion we're glad to
hear from you we'll get Christopher
Hitchins humble response no I like that
it doesn't get any better than that I
think we should speak for himself good
man I have a South Carolina good morning
morning I hate to disappoint the woman
that called earlier but I can't wait to
go buy your book I share every thought
in your head let me just let me ask you
brought up a good point is this now at
bookstores oh yes at fine bookstores
everywhere
and what about amazon.com or orders
online is now fifty no and Amazon comes
list yesterday I was pleased to see and
how much is it by the way well I think
that depends where you could buy it my
publishers of a to islet you cheap or to
slithery to actually put a price on the
cover but places like bands navel I
guess discount books I think it'll run
you there about eighteen dollars I think
that's I must say I think that's rather
a lot for such a small book but but if
you don't like the president um it'll
probably you'll probably worth it to you
and if you do it'll certainly be worth
it you go ahead caller I'm sorry you do
like the president's post eighteen
dollars you'll ever spend you say you'll
spend eighteen dollars for this well
you're pretty good at fifty well show up
around
I have distrusted him full bundle and
thank you for your book and now I'm
looking forward to reading it thank you
no question caller just a comment she
must hung up Phoenix Arizona good
morning for Christopher Hitchens yes sir
good morning good morning I just wanted
to comment on one of the calls that mr.
Hitchens received from the woman and it
was so great criticism and I think it is
typical of the non-thinking a liberal
segment of the population and I would
further opine that this country seems to
be now run by propaganda fear and
paranoia and Luke gun
well and then I would say next Cleveland
Ohio
good morning as far as what you're
stating basically you're only stating
your views on all of these don't said
anyone else's yeah hope I can't hear you
cuz I'm do you really have any facts to
back anything and secondly I am a
Democrat and I do wonder if George W
Bush seems to be leading the pack by 57%
or whatever it is now he hasn't said a
word yet
how could these Republicans back up
somebody that hasn't said anything I
think this is so stupid when this one is
he going to open his mouth
thank you Thank You caller do you ever
notice how people sometimes will say
when you've said something yourself they
say well that's only your opinion I just
think well yeah I mean that's true who
else's opinion could it could it
possibly be so understood it's a tick
some people do this
that's my reply to that as - that's the
assertions of fact yes I do in the book
contains one or two of those I mean the
most so to speak
damning or horrendous accusation against
the president which I've made elsewhere
and on in print and on the air that he
did wag the dog of a cartoon in August
and and Afghanistan in August and Iraq
in December I couldn't I wouldn't
believe me I'm not ducking your question
but I have put it out in print several
times no one has yet come up with a with
the argument that disproves the evidence
as I lay it out of the timeline aside
laid out the way for example I'll give
you one fact the president wouldn't
consult with Joint Chiefs about
launching this missiles he kept them out
of the decision wouldn't wouldn't talk
to the CIA or the FBI as far as possible
made a personal presidential matter of
Caprice and thus hit the wrong target
because there was no trying to find out
it was the wrong one and the reason for
the hurry was the Miss Lewinsky was due
that day to go back to the grand jury
things like that do you know how many
people who been asked to testify before
the Senate committee on the campaign
finance scandal which may turn into the
greatest scandal of all time if it turns
out to be connected to the Chinese
people's Republic's theft of
nuclear intelligence which I think it is
going to prove to be by the way how many
people of the Clinton fundraising
community were asked to come before that
committee and either fled the country
weekend future some justice or or took
refuge in the Fifth Amendment is a fact
for a 120 121 people currently refusing
by one means or another to say what they
know on the campaign finance question
that's a lot that really is quite a lot
of people in fact I think the political
corruption of the electoral process has
has never been as boldly practiced as by
any administration as by this one or by
any president is by this one I wouldn't
exempt you enrich Nixon from that
judgment we have a lot of emails let me
go through a couple of them one in Tampa
Florida Gloria blankly says the lady
insulting mr. Hitchens is no better than
the other enablers of this draft-dodging
president I'm finally hearing the truth
about this man another says there is no
one I would rather listen to than
Christopher Hitchens I disagree with his
political views but he is so profoundly
erudite the William Buckley of the left
that from J McCarthy of Marblehead
Massachusetts gore Vidal and William
Buckley to be called both in the same
show this is in the first half where we
posted our just about 40 minutes n with
the first woman so that's pretty good as
make that makes my day either one would
have made my day but both really does it
thank you
I don't deserve it then we get this a
from Jerry and Janice your guest is a
buffoon ah I was waiting for the other
shoe to drop
and as this your guest a Vanity Fair
makes me puke okay no the still they
can't take it away from me the other
vigilant but yourself they just can't
take it away for sure is that all
they're saying there there's more but
we're gonna get back to calls Worcester
Massachusetts for Christopher Hitchens
good morning good morning
mr. Hitchens I have a question early you
made the comment about President Clinton
making a comment to tarnish shillelagh
about her before Nixon over Johnson and
I just wanted antique silver Kennedy
although Kennedy excuse me I had a
question after the impeachment his first
press conference mr. Clinton told the
story about the man falling off the
cliff
and grabbing on to a branch I wanted to
know
because you know this administration
does he actually believe this when he
says it and believe this when he says
it's his cabinet members boards each
part of a strategy to infuriate his
enemies or fury his critics so they'll
speak out more against them therefore
his poll ratings go up more you have any
comment on it well it's a thing you have
to ask yourself all the time about
Clinton because the you can't you can't
make you can you can make it's like the
what used to call the [ __ ] paradox the
philosopher Zeno came up with saying all
cretins are all men from Crete are liars
but what if you're told that by someone
who is himself from Crete is that
statement still true if it's said by
someone who's full creative already the
Clinton paradox is the same you wonder
if he's lying even when he suspect you
might be telling the truth
for example he just on this matter of
the impeachment and the trial he said
that he had never read the Starr report
he said that he never watched any of his
own trial now suppose those statements
should be taken her face but he wanted
that he wanted this state was to be
believed why should he want people to
believe that he didn't even trouble to
read the document that had created all
this person that was the account of all
the trouble that he Clinton had put
everyone to and isn't it astonishing
that he want us to believe that he
wouldn't even watch his own trial by the
United States Senate then what was he
doing a step playing golf having phone
sex we don't know but if he wanted us to
believe that nothing birth or dress off
well what does he take us for what is he
really like and he thinks there's a
clever remarks to make so and she does
have a very lively sense of his own
self-interest and you can't say he's not
good at manipulating public opinion and
public opinion polls but these just seem
to me to be giveaways of a personality
that's just deeply rotten
does he know who you are I don't think
so well I wonder now he might if you had
the opportunity never met him I was
messing I lost him a question in New
Hampshire I asked him about this there's
the literally conduction of Ricky wrench
every turned his back on me wouldn't
answer that question if you had the
opportunity would you ask him a question
in a White House news conference no I
just go to this
I mean I've got a pass and so on but
I've stopped going because it's
humiliating like this business tomorrow
night of the White House Correspondents
Dinner
it's embarrassing as a member of the
profession to go to these things now
because you're being used as part of the
furniture you're you're part of the
effects you're part of the the the the
props the stage that it's degrading to
go I think and not that the president is
inhabited even much in the way press
conferences the sooner what one of the
many signs of them there's the Banana
Republic kind of regime that he's been
running is that he won't meet with the
press message
absolutely has to or unless you can
shelter behind or drag in as a prop of
some visiting dignitary who's worth 10
of him
LK man writes about the dinner you just
alluded to tomorrow night will have
coverage of the dinner which our
coverage gets underway at 9:30 East
Coast time al came and writes black tie
wires optional Michael Isikoff is
getting the Edgar Allen Poe award from
the White House Correspondents
Association and for a while the
president said that he was either not
going to show up or travel somewhere
else like Littleton Colorado or an Air
Force Base in Europe or sucking up and
going he's decided according to Al came
and to suck it up and go but he will not
be on hand for the award ceremony can
you explain yeah every year this is
terrible event at the Washington Hilton
where it's a where the press grovel to
the president and the president gravels
to the press it's a horrible thing to
see the president tries to show he's got
a sense of humor the press tries to show
tries to disprove what's already
obviously not true only that that it has
an adversarial relationship to the
president it's a humiliating evening a
lousy food and bad speeches and worst of
all because the journalistic profession
gives itself far too many of these as it
is prizes are handed out like party
favors
and Mike izikoff who was very good
proportions written very good Brooke has
got this prize and I was trying to
persuade him last week he came to my
book party in Los Angeles that he
shouldn't go up to be given the price to
open he's got the award that's an honor
if you like there's a small check put it
in the bank you don't have to go and be
part of the stage management of this
missive calling a liar and jerk and if
it was a corporation Newsweek wouldn't
let him do it
quite rightly I don't know what he
decided but now unfortunately Clint has
decided for him that he's not going to
be that hand him the awards it should
have been Michael who said I wouldn't be
I wouldn't take it from the president
anyway Ventura California
good morning well hi mr. Hitchin uh I
didn't vote for the president either
time and have never been much of a fan
of the president but if you compare this
president and presidency with the other
previous presidencies and the kinds of
things that happened inside those
administrations and the kind of foreign
policy that they use the kind of
economic policy that they used there's
you know this one they have this odd
style but in the end not a whole lot
different you know well I can certainly
see the force at that point but I I
would I'd add one observation there
which is part of the motive for my book
my book is in a way it's an address to
American liberals and American
liberalism when mr. Nixon and mr. Reagan
and mr. Bush did the sort of things I
imagine you have in mind either at home
or abroad there was always a section of
the population quite a large one in fact
in and in the Academy as well and on on
campus I mean by that and in my
profession and elsewhere who who at
least claimed they weren't taken invite
and were prepared to oppose it with mr.
Clinton however in acting for all
practical purposes a conservative
Republican agenda agenda is well I hate
that there's an alternative to liberals
went quiet they went to add they
couldn't criticize him in fact they
often not just went quiet where they
noisily defended him with completely
preposterous and illogical
syllogisms such as well it's a private
matter if he's corrupt it's his business
it's no concern of ours everybody lies
they said as if every way lied in that
way which meant that the in effect there
was no political opposition left in the
country except the accept the extreme
right or some of the extreme right and
the religious right well that that's the
situation we know been in before
whether consensus near consensus has
completely body guarded and absolutely
an absolute corruption worthless
politician so I thought that was that
made it for me more serious and so the
book is a report to all those who tried
to carry the guy when it was possible to
have foreseen through him Hawaii Hawaii
for Vanity Fair's Christopher Hitchens
good morning hi good morning I'm a
little bit nervous though you know bear
with me what time is it there um I
actually don't know I kind of sit up and
watch I sit down a lot what I wanted to
mention was um why it doesn't have an
opinion as to why is it that that case
is like so it's such a strong thing I
need I know I know him from a long time
ago um you know I used to admire him a
lot never you but I feel like he's
getting so consumed with it and it's not
good for him you know I I think that um
I don't know I I just I feel kind of bad
for him I feel bad for Bill claims and I
feel bad for him it's like the hatred
it's just it's making everybody do
things that maybe ordinarily you know
they wouldn't do and it's going around
so much I mean you hear it on talk radio
shows and you know and I mean like it's
just funny people could if they could
just step back a little bit like mr.
Hitchens for instances you could just
step back I mean he brought it back to
maybe the reason he hates Bill Clinton's
from the time when he bit that the
execution thing which I don't know the
full story of [ __ ]
I mean I just want to ask him you know I
just want to ask him as a human being to
another human being if he could try to
you know just step back a little bit and
try to see other things about Bill
Clinton he's not a perfect person he
really is he's very imperfect but it
does have good you know you know a good
side like everybody else I'm sure he
does met the hitches I'm sure you have
some things that are good about you I'd
be glad to think so honey as she says
she doesn't know about the Ricky Ray
rector case the killing of this
defenseless and disabled man but virtue
people do whereas if a Republican
candidate had tried to extricate himself
from a tough primary by killing a
lobotomized black man I think that me
without man would be very well known by
now some are things that liberals in the
press would have made a big stink about
it the appalling thing about Clinton is
that he's been able to do these things
and not be questioned by the liberal
community than a broad constituency
sorry I'm not going to step back cut
obliged you run up among other things I
hope booked sells I have to go out on
the road with nothing but a smile in the
shoeshine Seattle Washington good
morning I will never have never lose
before I'm absolutely nervous London and
no need to be nervous go ahead call it
well I felt the decisions for a long
time eyes of the nation and all that and
a good writer because he is very a today
one time and I'm not totally agree with
in the other time I do take on breach at
the description of sister mother trade
so that you know that the Ghul of
Calcutta I thought that was a bit much
but as far as um the third way that mr.
Clinton and mr. Blair who might throw on
the same boat are furthering is this
possible and NATO agenda part of that
and that's the third way they could to
account the cultural differences or is
it in fact uh their desire for a
monoculture
oligarchical type system
the override there are cultural
differences between people well yes it
does
though I'm not absolutely certain what
you know I think I'm going to make a
guess as to what you mean by the second
point but on the first one I think it
certainly is true of mr. Blair who is
politically you might sound you
logically sympathetic to Clinton and
similar turn in though I don't really
think Clinton has any ideology beyond
his own selfishness and the needs of the
hour but call them political twins if
you like and the third way is that they
may give to their project mr. Blair I
think has convinced himself over the
question of Serbia and Kosovo that it is
possible for people of his generation
born since the Second World War mr.
Blair's even younger than I am a to
fright of war that is definitely not
motivated by self-interest or by Empire
or by any of the things that people used
to suspect war of be motivated by and
that is international and legal and
humanitarian I mean I think he thinks
that that would be the achievement of
his generation so yes that's that's true
and I think he thinks it's true of this
war and I must say I think he's picked
the wrong war to say this about but one
of the things that makes watching this
nightmare in Kosovo so so appalling is
precisely that you can't say that the
war is being fought for a purpose that
is as advertised ignoble as advertised
the purpose is a noble one that's
pessimal corrupt you ought to me.they
I was taught when I was too Latin which
I know I'm not sure if it means the
worst is is the corruption of the best
if you were to write a profile of
Christopher Hitchens which adjectives
would you use to describe him I really
don't think that's a fair question
I mean
you'd have to ask somebody else but I
hope well know I'm really wishing I
should say what I hope would be said
can't do it we were you really up all
night I was up a lot of the knife why um
I've been I've had a lot of work to
catch up on there's a lot of work I've
got to do before I can go off on the
road which I'm about to talk about to
set off on a little tour of the country
beating the bushes at the smile of the
shoe-shiner coming into play when do you
work best major not as a matter of fact
probably a shame that children asleep
phone doesn't ring it's quiet except for
the you know screams and gunshots and
things like that in the book I like to
work a book dedicated to Laura and
Sophia yes my daughters how old are they
Sophia will be 10 this year and Antonio
would be six ten zocolo for a good
morning yes hello I won't turn this on
mute oh I won't I would like for you to
give me one statement that Clinton is
said to you that you could say he is the
direct fire you know perhaps at Oxford
or wherever one statement he is just
said directly to you to me personally
your beg your pardon to me personally me
pay your pardon
to me personally sir yes do you
personally you say you've known him so
socks hurt you know you know him back
when he was not referred I know I even
back then can you tell me one one well I
think I may have I may have let you get
the wrong impression I very carefully
said I did not know him at all sir I'm
contemporary of his and that I knew
other people who lived in his address
other contemporaries of his American and
British and so on but I've never met the
guy except for once in you Hampshire
where he wouldn't answer a question
asked about the I thought judicial
murder of
director was funny - who's he looking
very much for a change of subject from
Jennifer flowers which was all that my
colleagues would care about my thought
as a test of character surely executing
the lobotomized black madness war more
strenuous tests more interesting tests
than than lying by Jennifer flowers so
anyway I said well a governor I do have
another subject and he still turned as
if that would be nice and I asked him
about this he was turned his back and
walked away it was on the tarmac at some
Airport in New Hampshire Chicago good
morning Jessica Moines morning mr.
Hitchens good morning M I've watched you
over the last year and a half or
whatever now to admit I disagree with
most things that you say but I respect
the way you stick your guns and so I
would like to see perhaps with your very
direct acerbic form of journalism using
that and maybe a little bit more
positive way of highlighting other
things but I think you certain yourself
and also mr. William Bennett who I used
to completely disagree with I think a
lot of things you've said well actually
now seeing turned out to be true I'm not
talking about rapists or war criminals I
think that's a little bit below your
intellectual level too quite honest with
your Bernina
my question to you is there about the
cost of all crisis two very quick
questions what about this double
standard in the Rambouillet agreement
where one of the stipulations is that
the cost of Liberation Army is supposed
to be the arms are unarmed and here we
have the Western media now eulogizing
and another 20,000 people and whatever
and I've been feeling the Kosovo
Liberation Army's just doing the dirty
work for Clinton it doesn't have the
moral strength to send the troops in I
think he does it this and injustice to
the troops because I'm sure the Marines
the british paratroopers of French
Foreign Legion they would go in there
seeing what's going on coloring with
stop your net no because we are short on
time and we get a response from our
guest thanks for the call from Chicago
the Kosovo Liberation Army I know very
little about doing anyone don't trust
anyone who says they do know well
allegations have been made against it
that it's an extremely honest
organization that it's an extreme
Islamic organization and that it's a
drug dealing and narcotic smuggling
organization I don't know of any
evidence for any of those three
propositions and I know that
a lot of what is said about about Calais
is slanderous but I have a suspicion
that there's an accusation you could
make against it that would be true which
is that it's an extreme irredentist
nationalist organization by which i mean
to say that it wants in the end customer
to become part of a greater albania and
I think that the metastasis of the vile
idea of Milosevic greater Serbia a state
based on ethno fascism internally and
towards its neighbors the metastasis of
that will be greater Albania it'll be in
Milazzo [ __ ] fault but it won't be a
pretty thing to see and I think Western
policy should should be predicated on
the idea that Greater Albania would be a
bad idea to just as great as Serbians
Jacksonville Florida all right there
isn't imbalance yes good morning for
Christopher Hitchens
yes sir I'd like to say thank you mr.
Richardson for writing the book you have
two comments for you sir
one I'd like to find out what you know
of the Ford Foundation and if you
believe that the Quentin administration
is involved with it I've read several
books throughout the years on that
subject of a government a larger
government issue behind the behind the
scenes and also I'd like to correct mr.
Kelly who was on before you who said
that there are only about ten twelve
thousand people in the area of both Iraq
and the kasnia and the Kosovo area but
the fact is is that there's better than
50,000 people that are deployed from the
United States over there right now
military personnel a firm that's from
from the actual United States pre
deployed not stationed overseas there's
better than 50 almost 75,000 involved
and I believe it was just the other day
you had representative Gilman on board
on talking and he said that the war him
over there over in Iraq is has been is
over and I will hate to tell you this
and the people of America Duty's know
this your military is still out there on
the line every day flying over these
countries and nobody believes the war is
over even though we're not bombing every
day as we are now in Kosovo appreciate
the call thank you
I can't help him on the Ford Foundation
I'm sorry sir I have no information on
that
what is triangulation triangulation is
three-card Monte really it's a fancy
name for three-card Monte it's a name
the fancy name is coined by Dick Morris
a sleazy political consultant
ultra-conservative used to well for
Jesse Helms unscrupulous money man and
bagman and occasional procurer of women
also for the president and until
recently
he's only male friend the area of
triangulation as a strategy as this you
you steal the Republican Party's program
adopted for the Democratic Party
hope you can bring the donors along
Republican Party's donors along with you
which you often can then you're faced
with the task of shoring up or
reassuring your own constituency and
that's done by means of a sort of cheap
and superficial political correctness by
which I mean mister Clinton was very
good at going to different
constituencies and suggesting that they
wouldn't be safe if there was a
Republican majority to women about
abortion for example to some civil
libertarians about the Supreme Court
he's very good at resorting to that kind
of thing when in a corner for example on
this China scandal which I think still
might be the death of him if half of
what we suspect is true his first
response is to say but this is just a
Shin bashing now no one had done any
Asian mashing there was no suggestion at
all
wasn't I think even in under turn of
chauvinism in the pointing out that no
mr. Clinton's donors were acting for
foreign powers and major Asian foreign
corporations immediately he turns it
into an for anyone said anything well
this is Asian bashing as if to appeal to
you know a latent rainbow coalition
that's the way the trick is pulled and
that's that's where triangulation gets
you in the end by the way is you may
know we're spending a lot of time on
this network looking at the 41 men who
have served in the White House forty-one
American presidents 42 but one serve
non-consecutive terms what is a fair
amount of time in order to judge
President Clinton through the prism of
history oh I think his place in history
is secure already
I mean I really don't think that's
pretty much doubt about it that people
will say his was a regime of nothingness
punctuated by nastiness oh eight years
eaten by the locust the time when the
possibility of denuclearizing and
disarming large parts of the world who's
the first real post Cold War President
was simply thrown away with a chance to
rebuild a different relationship with
Russia was thrown away in the same way
where the most sorted imaginable
relationship was however developed with
China in the most cynical possible now
where the worst kinds of political
trickery were practiced where the
healthcare argument was lost perhaps for
in a whole other generation and where
the standard of public life and of what
what can be expected of a public servant
was allowed just to collapse in freefall
when nothing was punctuated by nastiness
this what it was you don't need to wait
for a verdict on mr. Clinton the book no
one left to lie to by Christopher
Hitchens now out published by Russell we
are a sir thank you very much for being
with us it was a pleasure thanks for
having me